we talked about this kerfuffle between
Saudi Arabia and Canada that started
when a Canadian official called out
Saudi Arabia on Twitter for their human
rights record understandably and the
oppression of dissidents and journalists
and specifically Canada was calling for
the release of jailed women's rights
activists and Saudi Arabia immediately
pushed back against canada's human
rights record and you might say what
what what human rights record of
canada's was there to push back against
and we've now learned that as Saudi
Arabia was doing this as Saudi Arabia
was criticizing Canada for their human
rights records they crucified a man at
Mecca for theft and murder first of all
what would Saudi Arabia criticize about
Canada it's kind of a weird thing it's a
weird combination of things number one
Saudi Arabia criticized the arrest in
Canada of a Holocaust denier named Ernst
zündel
who was convicted of spreading false
news in the harm of public interest
Saudi Arabia felt that that was a
violation of Human Rights
Saudi Arabia criticized Canada because
Jordan Peterson's something it was like
some people don't like Jordan Peterson
and what Jordan Peterson says even
though Peterson has never been arrested
that was part of the Saudi critique of
the Canadian human rights record that
rampant Jordan Peterson is a prisoner of
conscience I think they said Saudi
Arabia says I mean it's it's almost like
I'm leading reading an onion article
Saudi Arabia says that Canada has a high
rate of persecution of women hardly true
about Canada but very true about Saudi
Arabia and Saudi Arabia also in the
middle of all this put a picture on
social media of a plane crashing into
buildings in Toronto sort of reminiscent
of the 9/11 attacks carried out of
course mostly by Saudi individuals but
then when the public was appalled by
that they republished the picture sons
the plane the plane had been removed
from the picture so the criticisms by
Saudi Arabia of Canada make no sense
whatsoever but meanwhile they crucified
a guy as part of a state sanctioned
capital punishment death penalty
incident that is regularly carried out
by this extremist Muslim theocracy a man
in Saudi Arabia was accused of Seir
serious crimes no one
that breaking into a woman's home
shooting and stabbing her which killed
her really really horrific crime and the
country decided that the punishment for
this man would be crucifixion which is
when you publicly hang the body after
the execution has taking place taking
place backwards totally Dark Ages
practice and what we need to be doing
immediately is getting away from fossil
fuels altogether because then Saudi
Arabia's alliance with the United States
becomes increasingly irrelevant
partially so there's this immoral
alliance that I've pointed out for a
decade at this point with Saudi Arabia
and our continued sale of more and more
weapons to Saudi Arabia as part of it
our shared goal of Middle East Middle
East stability mostly based on oil is a
big factor if you stop using oil you
stop needing oil and you can get away
from the Saudi Arabian alliance
however it's now a lot more complex
because we make money off of Saudi
Arabia military-industrial complex
companies make money selling Saudi
Arabia weapons defense contractors make
money doing business with Saudi Arabia
so now it's much more intertwined than
oil but this is like the last country
that we should be having an alliance
with yeah one would think that we would
have more of an alignment with Canada on
this because it's about human rights
yeah but the Trump administration is
staying silent on this yeah meanwhile
we're ramping up the tariffs on Canada
yet there are no sanctions on Saudi
Arabia and we just gave them a 110
billion dollar arms deals yeah it's all
messed up so Saudi Arabia is epically
hypocritical by saying that Canada's
human rights are a problem but then all
the countries that do business with
Saudi Arabia like the United States but
claim to care about human rights are
also huge hypocrites and this may well
lead to Canada cutting ties with Saudi
Arabia which I would love to see because
those ties are a disaster and as a quick
reminder to that kind of like paint the
the broader picture for you here Saudi
Arabia is a member of the United Nations
Human Rights Council they crucify people
as part of state sanctioned death
penalty proceedings I cannot imagine
something more ridiculous and immoral
today's program
sponsored in part by Blink asam / Pakman
I've talked about blinkers before it's
this awesome app that I've been using
for several months now and what it does
is take the best and most critically
acclaimed non-fiction books and
condenses them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
you could listen to ten books in an
afternoon I know that many in our
audience want to expand their horizons
and learn more about all sorts of
different topics but we're mostly
limited by time to some degree I know
I'm not able to read all of the books
that I want simply because I've got
other stuff going on and that's why
blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to be li NK is t.com slash PA k ma n